>>Emily Pittman: Travel
journals are the textbooks
that our kids create themselves.
They're a great way for students
to really take ownership
of their learning.
>>Denver Huffstutler: We
call them travel journals
because it becomes a journey of
all their engaging activities.
>>Emily Pittman: So this is
a blank-slate travel journal
from the module that
we're currently doing,
"Follow Me Through Tennessee".
>>Lydia: When they start out
they're all just a blank book.
We get to create a page about
our learning about that subject,
and it's fun because
you get to tie it in.
You get to keep them at
the end of the session.
>>Emily Pittman: So the table
of contents the kids put
in at the beginning so that
we can hand them the materials
and say, "Okay, open
up to page nine.
We're gonna be working on our
history of West Tennessee page,"
and it gives kids the main idea
of what that page will be about.
>>Here we have our
essential questions.
>>Those questions are really
the basis of every single one
of our lessons that we teach.
One of our leaves says, "How
does change occur over time?
How does where you live
affect how you live?"
>>Denver Huffstutler: If you
look at the travel journals,
everything that's in there, it's
"Here's how I understand how
to answer the essential question
that I was looking to uncover."
>>Emily Pittman: Well, "I
wonder" questions are done
at the very beginning
of modules.
We usually give them
a little bit
of background information
with our hook lesson.
So we posted these four topics
on the board and prompted them,
"We want you to think
of an 'I wonder'."
Little Lucy, here, wondered
how Tennessee became a state.
It's an easy assessment to know
what we need to cover a lot
or what we don't need
to cover so much.
>>Denver Huffstutler: --
only about twenty-five
to twenty-eight lessons
within a quarter
that we put together.
We not only want
to include things
that the student has learned,
but we also want there
to be reflective times and those
are things that we can assess.
>>Jill Levine: These
travel journals are rich
with timelines, charts,
diagrams,
lots of writing,
vocabulary, pictures.
>>Emily Pittman: We
provide our lesson.
We then-- usually
we have a prompt
that they respond
to after the lesson.
They do their draft and
put it into written form.
We talk about ways
that they can revise
and correct their mistakes.
So then their published pieces
turn into their travel journals.
>>Teacher: Right now I'd
like to see you guys flipping
through making sure
all pages are complete,
making sure that you have titles
and headings on every page.
In the middle of the table
you'll find your rubric.
>>Denver Huffstutler: A rubric
is a simple way for students
to judge their own
understanding of content
or completion of an assignment.
>>Emily Pittman: The
rubric, it's a reflection
of the table of contents.
>>Grady: You can grade yourself
in what do you think it is
and the teacher grades
what you got.
If you got, like, a
check-minus right here,
you know now what
you can work on.
>>Denver Huffstutler: As
students go into older grades,
the rubric tends to be a little
bit more specific of things
that have to be there.
So it's a great tool
for the student
to redirect their own learning.
>>Emily Pittman: The covers are
usually completed towards the
end of quarter once they
have a full understanding
and we do some kind of main idea
of that module on
the front cover.
>>Finn: A travel journal
is very fun to do,
because you really get to
show what you have learned.
>>Hayden: I get to
show all my work
that I've done working
really hard in school
to my parents and to my teacher.
>>Jill Levine: What's
really special
about travel journals is they
really become prize possessions
for our students.
If they're here for eight
years and they've created four
of these every year,
they'll have thirty-two,
and so most of our students
will have a shelf at home
where all their travel
journals are lined up
and parents often say that
that's the bedtime reading.
That's what they most want
to go back to, is they want
to read those travel journals.
When students are engaged,
when they're getting their hands
dirty, when they're creating,
when they're painting,
when they're thinking
and problem solving, that's
when true learning takes place.